من يومين عقد قران او قران الاميره ايمان
ابنه الملك عبد الله ملك الاردن في حفل
ملكي تابعوا العالم كله اخباره وصوره وصلت
كل انحاء العالم حقيقه حتى من قبل الفرح
يعني من وقت الاعلان عنه وعن ترتيباته وفي
اهتمام كبير فيه قبل الفرح كان في حفله
حنا انتشرت منا مقاطع كثيره ووقتها في هذه
الحفله ما ظهرت الاميره سلمى اللي هي
الابنه الصغرى للملك عبد الله والملكه
رانيا وشقيقه الاميره ايمان وغيابها تساءل
الاردنيين وغيرهم عنه ولمن كثرت الاسئله
طلعت مصادر مقربه من العائله المالكه
وصرحت للاعلام انه غياب الاميره سلمى عن
الحنه كان بسبب الدراسه الجامعيه في
الخارج وانها راح تكون حاضره في الزفاف
وفعلا من يومين شفناها في حفل الزفاف الى
جانب والدها ووالدتها واشقائها اليوم
الامير حسين ولي العهد الاردني فاجا
الاردنيين على حساباته ببو للاشاعات اللي
طلعت عن غياب شقيقته ولفت الانظار بخفه
الدم فالامير نشر صوره له مع خطيبته رجوى
سيف وشقيقته الاميره سلمى والصوره من
الفرح وعلق عليها وكتب لقينا سلمى وعلى
فكره الملكه رانيا عملت ريبوسيه كمان
للستوري عندها ومن اكثر الاشياء الملفته
قبل الفرح كانت اغنيه خاصه نشرتها الملكه
رانيا بمناسبه زفاف ابنتها بصوت اليسا
وكلام ولحن مروان خوري وشكرتهم على
الاهداء وامس نشرت الملكه الاغنيه كامله
بعد ما كانت نشرت منها بس مقطع قبل ومعها
لما نشرتها كامله نشرت معك كمان صور
وفيديوهات من الحفل والاغنيه للان محققه
مشاهدات مليونيه على حساب الملكه باكثر من
ثمانيه ونصف مليون مشاهده
على دربك
على دورك خطوه خطوه تمشي
والنجم الليل بعرسك بايدك تقلب كمشي
ربي انت السامع
صوتي
لصوتك طالع
بدعي لاغلى
انساني يا ربي انت العاطي ليلي بتسمع
دعواتك فرحك تحضن الايماني
ملهم
للورد والياسمين
يا عروسه
[موسيقى]
يا امير هالحلوين